what's going on guys
Walking Dead is lumbering back into your
television sets this weekend are you
excited for it or do you think the show
deserves a spike in the brain we have
two sides here to debate is Walking Dead
a worthwhile program still first on the
pro side you know them from good
mythical morning and so many YouTube
videos rhett and Link glad to win this
debate and the anti Walking Dead side
first he is a man of how many voices one
kajillion one kajillion voices rock
Baker
he's the excellent director and editor
of our program and honest trailers Dan
Merle Walking Dead it's coming back
you guys kind of pumped for it I'm a
little behind Metro yeah he's on a
Netflix schedule you can't hold that
against the man listen it's a testimony
to the strength of the show that I don't
even have to be up up to the end of it
to know how great it is or is it a
testimony to your fandom that you don't
like it that much he has me will you
guys be watching Walking Dead when it
returns this weekend I don't not not the
week by week I don't know that's a
little unbearable like watching on
Netflix not as bad cuz you know you can
if there's a bad episode yeah just watch
the next one the characters do we care
about them do you care about these
people anymore
I do care about them and I think the
beautiful thing about the structure of
the show is that when there is a
character who you don't care about or
has become annoying which happens on a
regular basis there's always the hope
that they will be murdered and you can
hate watch you can hate watch those
character keeps you going
you remember how annoying of a character
Shane was he was killed twice as a human
and as a zombie that is so satisfying do
you guys care about my argument is the
exact opposite
oh don't care about the characters okay
we're that exact reason because there's
no reason to get invested in any of them
because they're just gonna kill them off
randomly whenever they decide to okay so
what do we think about the writing
they've had numerous show runners is
that has the show consistent no this
show was doomed the day that Frank that
they got rid of Frank terribly great it
wasn't the zombie splatter show that a
see wanted and they got rid of them I
think we have to establish some context
here right yeah okay if somebody comes
to town and they're like I want to eat a
fine restaurant I say okay I'm gonna
recommend an actual fine restaurant I'm
gonna recommend Breaking Bad I'm gonna
madman I'm gonna recommend high quality
perfect television but if they come into
town and they're like where can I get a
hot dog mm-hmm you know I got a couple
of hot dog places I'm gonna recommend
Walking Dead is the hot dog of
television
you can't expect too much from it you
can't compare it to so iSchool it's made
out here clothes and snouts would you
what you love that pig anus um so uh how
do you guys feel about these zombie
attacks is like oh my god this that can
we think of a new way to do this or I
mean they they do get a little tedious
whoo after a while it's like how many
times can the same scene basically
happen my wife if I told her hey you're
gonna watch something like walking dead
she never never in her life does she
want to see any of that blood or gore
right but it's a gateway drug for people
like my wife she's sitting there looking
at humans smush other humans heads and
like rotten pumpkin yeah and she's into
it now yeah yeah so it's a good gateway
drug for that much harder stuff now you
and your wife watch snuff films together
it's now a possibility yeah totally your
own ATO do that the show also is about
the dynamics between people and who they
run into on the road is the show more
about that and it's set and those
murders are more satisfying yeah that's
an actual human being killed it prepares
you us all of us emotionally for what's
gonna happen when the zombie apocalypse
actually comes I mean I would have so
much emotions tied to me offing link
when he turns over now is the moment he
turns he's going out he's out you won't
you won't when you have to murder link
you won't even blink it mad at all we do
you win I've been sorry my going for I
think a big problem of the show is the
seasons are too long if the seasons were
10 episodes it might be a solid show but
there's just too there's too little
story too much time what's the ratio of
awesome episode to throwaway episodes
about a Ford
ratio for bad episode for slow epistemic
I say bad but for slow episodes to
everyone or it could be a accurate
simulation of what the apocalypse is
really gonna feel like oh man I know
there's zombies lurking I got four
episodes of just trying to survive I'm a
little bored and now hitting the fan
it's a teaching tool guys you can't just
engineer something for your perfect
entertainment purposes it's has got to
fit into the context of your life and
your marriage I don't know if you guys
are married or not but when you get
married the highlight becomes sitting
down and watching television with your
wife binge watching yeah the key to us
liking the show is to get married yes I
really think it changes everything guys
so Dan I want to ask uh you said the
show is like inherently flawed is it
just the format of it because in the
comic books comic books are kind of
engineered to just go on forever
TV shows not built the same way don't
touch on that a little bit well they're
following the compact format and they
acknowledge that they're following the
comic format in that there is no end
game and basically I'll tell you how the
show works bad stuff happens they go on
the road they think they find someplace
good it turns out to be bad and it just
goes like that
some might say if it ain't broke don't
fix it the best movies in the world are
not the ones that are just chock-full of
plot points in action right that's a
Michael Bay movie and we're not nobody's
making that argument right no no so for
me it did just take a recent upswing
I'm reintroduce a season but now it's
like what is this place man they're
going to terminus their terminus by the
way spoiler alert it's not yeah but
they're gonna they're gonna get there
and at the end they're gonna be inside
of a train car locked up that sounds
great
I will say speaking of people dying if
Daryl dies I'm out any show that can
make you say that about them and with
that haircut is a powerful show tell me
what do you two want besides a shorter
season what do you two want to see
ideally in the next season
let's les uh Rick
Karl I'd like to see some indication of
I think that's the Blacky bags biggest
problem in the endless journey the
endless journey and also I think the
show is uh nimble I don't think there's
any way to end this show that does that
matter yeah I don't want it to end but I
do want it to progress I do want to move
from just survival to some sort of
solution even if it's a even if the bad
one and then I'm disappointed you know
getting a little more progress on the on
the scientific front compelling points
from each side but let's make our
closing statements I'm going to ask each
of you to speak as if you're talking to
someone who's never seen maybe you've
never heard of the show why should they
avoid it or why should they watch it
someone who has been asleep for five
years like Rick or maybe an Amish person
okay so uh let's start with the anti
side do you like the same plot lines
over and over again with the same
archetypes over and over again
tune into The Walking Dead it never ends
I think I should be on the poster The
Walking Dead it never had never ends
rhett and Link if you want to experience
the zombie apocalypse the way it's
supposed to be experienced this is the
show to watch I mean it opens up a whole
world that you started even granted it
things get drugged out how long are they
gonna have the flu how long are they
gonna be on this farm you know what just
go with it
you all start to feel like you were in
the zombie apocalypse that's the motto
The Walking Dead just go with it feel
the apocalypse so are you gonna just go
with it and feel the apocalypse or are
you gonna avoid this never-ending
journey let us know in the comments
section below
the best answer we're gonna send you a
DVD or blu-ray of season one of Rick and
Morty really funny show courtesy of our
friends at Adult Swim I want to thank
our awesome panel rhett and Link check
them out on YouTube if you're not
already funny stuff rock Baker check him
out on YouTube thanks for being here and
Dan Moreau I see that guy all the time
I'm Hal Rudnick thank you for watching
hit me up on Twitter bye bye oh one more
thing do you guys want more screen
junkies too bad we're giving it to you
anyway starting this Sunday check out
our new show screen
these movie fights you can find it right
here or find it on iTunes
awesome debates good friends sweet times
we are partnering with movie talk nation
the home of the schmoes you know them so
in the words of the great Ken Watanabe
that's a night most comic book fans
would agree that the bill bixby lou
ferrigno show was one of the best
superhero shows ever most of the time